[موسيقى]
الذي لم يكن مدغدغًا باللون الوردي عندما يرون
صغار الأفيال ولكن هذا
المراسل الطموح كان في الواقع مندهشًا وعطل
دائرة الحياة
أثناء محاولته تصوير عرض موقف لصالح
هيئة الإذاعة الكينية من شأنه أن
ينقذ الأنواع البرية لدينا ويوفر منزلًا
[  ضحك]
فعل أحد المعلقين
المتدربين ، مراسل ألفين كاونتر ، قال
لراديو غيتو إنه قام بعشر مرات
لمحاولة تثبيت موقفه عندما سمّره جذع الفيل ،
شعرت فقط
بجذع الفيل ، لكنني حاولت الحفاظ على
هدوئي ، الفيل يتيم اسمه كيم داني
يعيش  في صندوق شيلدريك للحياة البرية
في كينيا ، وصفها أحد الحراس بأنها واحدة
من أذكى الأفيال الذين قابلهم على الإطلاق ،
تعلمت ألفين درسًا تعلمته مبكرًا
في وظيفتي الأولى في التلفزيون مثل صديقي
هنا ، تسرق الحيوانات العرض سواء كان خنزيرًا أو
فرس النهر يبدو أنها تحبها  أن تكون أمي على ما يرام ،
فقط تمزح بدلاً من
أن تقضم بصوت عالي.
جذع صغير
لديك
سي إن إن نيويورك البشرية